Speaker 1: So we're continuing to fight
misinformation about vaccines and it's really
becoming a game of whack a mole at this point.
Vaccination is the way out of the pandemic. We
are seeing a rapid rise in cases, cases up. Sixty
nine percent in the United States since the bottom
a few weeks ago. Told you about that yesterday or
the day before. And one thing that really makes me
sick of the covid vaccine conspiracy's is that
some of them so obviously don't make sense. And
yet they keep getting repeated. They become
mimetic and viral. The vaccine has metal and
it magnetize is you. That was going around for a
while. In fact, I told the story of my lift driver
in Miami. I got to Miami for vacation a couple
of weeks ago, get into a car mast. Of course,
I was wearing 12 masks and a helmet and the
lift driver says, Oh, no, no, no, I'm not
getting vaccinated because my mom got the second
dose and then her whole body became magnetized.
That's one. Another one is the vaccine modifies
your DNA. It's called an MRI and a vaccine. You
inject it and then your DNA becomes modified. It's
almost like you become some kind of hybrid being
the vaccine can give you. The virus is another one
that was earlier on and one that's been floating
around for a little bit now. Is that simply being
around vaccinated people could do things to you.
And the term that they've come up with is shedding
vaccine, sort of an analogous term to the concept
of shedding virus particles when you're sick.
Here's one example. This is Deana Lorrain. Deanna
Lauraine is a Republican conspiracy theorist who
ran for California's 12th Congressional District
last year, lost the primary. She's explaining to
some guy, I don't even know who this is about,
how she was around vaccinated people and her
period got all messed up. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: When I took a little trip last month,
I was telling you about with a couple of my
liberal friends last last month for a
weekend. We were in close quarters. I
they had all been vaccinated. And I'm the
only one that hadn't been vaccinated already.
Speaker 1: A red flag. Right. OK, good.
Speaker 5: And it's a mistake that
I'll never make again.
Speaker 1: And I wish she
was saying the mistake was not being vaccinated,
but that's not where she's going with this life.
Speaker 5: But I missed my period
and yeah, again, sorry, earmuffs,
but I miss my period and I haven't received
it since. I'm freaking out a little bit. I'm
scared because could I be infertile now?
Speaker 1: So the first question is,
if you're that freaked out, don't
you call a doctor, right? Like,
why are you reporting it to Stu Peters? Maybe
is this guy's name? Why haven't you why wouldn't
you already have asked your doctor about it?
Speaker 5: The vaccine shedding is real. It's
causing lots of different side effects,
including missed periods in women,
infertility, early menopause in women in
their thirties. And now I've experienced
it firsthand and I need to protect myself. I'm
no longer going to be around vaccinated women
because I need to care about my fertility.
Speaker 1: And I can you imagine. So there's
a couple there's a few things there, first of
all. The where to even start. So, no, no evidence
of early menopause related to the vaccine, no
evidence of infertility related to the vaccine,
but there's really two parts here. First, is
the vaccine causing mist periods if you get
the vaccine versus whether you could miss a period
from being near someone who has been vaccinated.
Let's do the latter first. There is no way to be
affected by people around you being vaccinated
other than you will be less likely to get the
virus and you will be less likely to end up in
the hospital and you will be less likely to die
thanks to people around you being vaccinated.
If you were sick with covid, your body can release
virus particles as you cough, et cetera. So you
can be if you're sick, you can be shedding the
virus. That's true. Unless you were vaccinated
with a vaccine that contains live virus, which
the covid vaccines do not, your body can't shed
vaccine particles or virus particles, whatever it
is that you call them. There's no physiological
mechanism for it to happen with the vaccines
that are being used in the United States.
Vincent Van Gogh, who's an assistant professor
of pharmaceutical sciences, says, quote, It is
possible to have viral shedding after a vaccine,
but that requires a vaccine with a live virus to
be used as the basis for the vaccine. That is not
the basis of the covid vaccines used in the United
States. The only way for this to potentially
happen is to have a live attenuated vaccine.
It has a weakened version of the germ that causes
the disease. None of our covid vaccines in the US
do that with the live virus. Now, in terms
of vaccines affecting the periods of women
who get vaccinated, women's periods and the
immune system are very, very much connected.
As a woman is about to ovulate, her immune system
ramps itself up to prevent any infectious agents
from maybe interfering with the fertilization
and implantation of an egg so that you can
successfully start a pregnancy. This is like
reproductive science. Once the egg is fertilized
and implant's, the immune system dampens to
accept the pregnancy. The uterus has immune cells.
Those can be affected by hormonal changes. The
immune system and cortisol, the stress hormone
are related and periods respond very strongly to
cortisol levels. So the long and short of that is
it's being studied. There are anecdotal reports of
a late period after the second dose in some women.
We don't yet know whether it's related to the
vaccine. It's conceivable that the vaccine might
impact one or two period the timing of one
or two periods following the second dose,
because your immune system is hard at
work, developing immunity to the virus
and or due to the elevated cortisol levels,
there's no evidence of an impact on fertility.
There's no evidence of a long term effect. And
remember, this woman wasn't even vaccinated
herself. She's claiming just by being near
vaccinated people, she believes her menstruation
was affected. So this is really wild stuff and
these are sticky ideas that are not going away